The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Begin
with a new topic,
which is breakdown of classical
statistical mechanics.
So we developed a formalism
to probabilistically describe
collections of large particles.
And once we have that, from that
formalism calculate properties
of matter that have to do
with heat, temperature,
et cetera, and things
coming to equilibrium.
So question is, is this
formalism always successful?
And by the time you come to
the end of the 19th Century,
there were several things
that were hanging around that
had to do with thermal
properties of the matter
where this formalism
was having difficulties.
And the difficulties
ultimately pointed out
to emergence of
quantum mechanics.
So essentially, understanding
the relationship
between thermodynamics,
statistical mechanics,
and properties of matter was
very important to development
of quantum mechanics.
And in particular, I will
mention three difficulties.
The most important one
that really originally set
the first stone for
quantum mechanics
is the spectrum of
black body radiation.
And it's basically
the observation
that you heat something.
And when it becomes hot,
it starts to radiate.
And typically, the color of
the radiation that you get
is a function of
temperature, but does not
depend on the properties of the
material that you are heating.
So that has to do with heat.
And you should be
able to explain
that using
statistical mechanics.
Another thing that we
have already mentioned
has to do with the third
law of thermodynamics.
And let's say the heat capacity
of materials such as solids.
We mentioned this
Nernst theorem that
was the third law
of thermodynamics
based on observation.
Consequence of it was that
heat capacity of most things
that you can measure go to 0
as you go to 0 temperature.
We should be able to
explain that again,
based on the phenomena of
statistical-- the phenomenology
of thermodynamics and the
rules of statistical mechanics.
Now, a third thing that
is less often mentioned
but is also important has
to do with heat capacity
of the atomic gases such as
the air in this room, which
is composed of, say,
oxygen and nitrogen that
are diatomic gases.
So probably, historically they
were answered and discussed
and resolving the order
that I have drawn for you.
But I will go backwards.
so we will first
talk about this one,
then about number two--
heat capacity of solids--
and number three about
black body radiation.
OK.
Part of the reason is that
throughout the course,
we have been using our
understanding of the gas
as the sort of measure
of how well we understand
thermal properties
of the matter.
And so let's stick with
the gas and ask, what do I
know about the heat capacity
of the gas in this room?
So let's think
about heat capacity
of dilute diatomic gas.
It is a gas that is sufficiently
dilute that it is practically
having ideal gas law.
So PV is roughly
proportional to temperature.
But rather than thinking
about its pressure,
I want to make sure I
understand something
about the heat capacity, another
quantity that I can measure.
So what's going on here?
I have, let's say, a box.
And within this box,
we have a whole bunch
of these diatomic molecules.
Let's stick to the
canonical ensemble.
So I tell you the volume
of this gas, the number
of diatomic molecules,
and the temperature.
And in this formalism, I
would calculate the partition
function.
Out of that, I should
be able to calculate
the energy, heat
capacity, et cetera.
So what do I have to do?
I have to integrate over all
possible coordinates that
occur in this system.
To all intents and purposes,
the different molecules
are identical.
So I divide by the
phase space that
is assigned to each one of them.
And I said it is dilute
enough that for all intents
and purposes, the pressure is
proportional to temperature.
And that occur, I
know, when I can
ignore the interactions
between particles.
So if I can ignore the
interactions between particles,
then the partition function
for the entire system
would be the product of
the partition functions
that I would write for
the individual molecules,
or one of them raised
to the N power.
So what's the Z1 that
I have to calculate?
Z1 is obtained by
integrating over
the coordinates and momenta
of a single diatomic particle.
So I have a factor of d cubed p.
I have a factor of d cubed q.
But I have two particles, so
I have d cubed p1, d cubed q1,
d cubed p2, d cubed
q 2, and I have
six pairs of coordinate momenta.
So I divide it by h cubed.
I have e to the minus beta
times the energy of this system,
which is p1 squared over
2m p2 squared over 2m.
And some potential
of interaction
that is responsible for bringing
and binding these things
together.
So there is some V that
is function of q1 and q2
that binds the two particles
together and does not
allow them to become separate.
All right, so what
do we do here?
We realize that immediately for
one of these particle,s there
is a center of mass that
can go all over the place.
So we change
coordinates to, let's
say, Q, which is
q1 plus q2 over 2.
And corresponding to the
center of mass position,
there is also a center
of mass momentum, P,
which is related to p1 minus p2.
But when I make the change
of variables from these
coordinates to these
coordinates, what I will get
is that I will have
a simple integral
over the relative coordinates.
So I have d cubed Q d
cubed big P h cubed.
And the only thing that
I have over there is
e to the minus beta p squared
divided by 2 big M. Big M
being the sum total
of the two masses.
If the two masses are
identical, it would be 2M.
Otherwise, it would
be M1 plus M2.
And then I have an integration
over the relative coordinate.
Let's call that q
relative momentum p
h cubed e to the minus
beta p squared over 2 times
the reduced mass here.
And then, the
potential which only
is a function of the
relative coordinate.
Point is that what I have done
is I have separated out this 6
degrees of freedom that
make up-- or actually,
the 3 degrees of freedom and
their conjugate momenta that
make up a single molecule into
some degrees of freedom that
correspond to the center of
mass and some degrees of freedom
that correspond to
the relative motion.
Furthermore, for
the relative motion
I expect that the
form of this potential
as a function of the separation
has a form that is a minimum.
Basically, the particles
at 0 temperature
would be sitting
where this minimum is.
So essentially, the shape
of this diatomic molecule
would be something like this
if I find its minimum energy
configuration.
But then, I can allow
it to move with respect
to, say, the minimum energy.
Let's say it occurs
at some distance d.
It can oscillate around
this minimum value.
If it oscillates around
this minimum value,
it basically will explore
the bottom of this potential.
So I can basically think of
this center of mass contribution
to the partition function.
And this contribution
has a part that
comes from these oscillations
around the center of mass.
Let's call that u.
Then, there is the
corresponding momentum.
I don't know, let's call it pi.
I divide by h and I
have e to the minus beta
pi squared over 2 mu.
And then I have minus beta.
Well, to the lowest
order, I have
v of d, which is a constant.
And then I have some
frequency, some curvature
at the bottom of
this potential that I
choose to write as
mu omega squared
over 2 multiplying by u squared.
Essentially, what
I want to do is
to say that really, there is a
vibrational degree of freedom
and there is a harmonic
oscillator that describes that.
The frequency of that is
related to the curvature
that I have at the
bottom of this potential.
So this degree of freedom
corresponds to vibrations.
But that's not the end of this
story because here I had three
q's.
One of them became the
amplitude of this oscillation.
So basically, the relative
coordinate is a vector.
One degree of freedom
corresponds to stretching,
but there are two
other components of it.
those two other
components correspond
to essentially keeping
the length of this fixed
but moving in the
other directions.
What do they correspond to?
They correspond to rotations.
So then there is essentially
another partition function
that I want right here.
That corresponds to the
rotational degrees of freedom.
Now, the rotational
degrees of freedom
have a momentum contribution
because this p is also
three components.
One component went
in to the vibrations.
There are two more
components that
really combine to tell
you about the angular
momentum and the energy that
is proportional to the square
of the angular momentum.
But there is no
restoring force for them.
There is no corresponding
term that is like this.
So maybe I will just write
that as an integral over angles
that I can rotate this thing.
An integral over
the two components
of the angular momentum
divided by h squared.
There's actually two angles.
And the contribution is e
to the minus beta angular
momentum squared over 2I.
So I wrote the entire thing.
So essentially,
all I have done is
I have taken the
Hamiltonian that
corresponds to
two particles that
are bound together and
broken it into three pieces
corresponding to the center
of mass, to the vibrations,
and to the rotations.
Now, the thing is
that if I now ask,
what is the energy that I would
get for this one particle--
I guess I'll call this Z1-- what
is the contribution of the one
particular to the energy
of the entire system?
I have minus the log Z1
with respect to beta.
That's the usual formula
to calculate energies.
So I go and look at
this entire thing.
And where do the beta
dependencies come from?
Well, let's see.
So my Z1 has a part that comes
from this center of mass.
It gives me a V. We expect that.
And then from the
integration over the momenta,
I will get something like 2 pi
m over beta h squared to the 3/2
power.
From the vibrations--
OK, what do I have?
I have e to the minus beta V
of d, which is the constant.
We really don't care.
But there are these
two components
that give me root 2
pi mu divided by beta.
There is a
corresponding thing that
comes from the variance that
goes with this object, which
is square root of 2 pi divided
by beta mu omega squared.
The entire thing
has a factor of 1/h.
So this is the vibrations.
And for the rotations,
what do I get?
I will get a 4 pi
from integrating
over all orientations.
Divided by h squared.
I have essentially the two
components of angular momentum.
So I get essentially, the square
of 2 pi I divided by beta.
So this is rotations.
And this is center of mass.
We can see that if
I take that formula,
take its log divide by-- take
a derivative with respect
to beta.
First of all, I will
get this constant
that is the energy of the
bond state at 0 temperature.
But the more interesting
things are the things
that I take from the derivatives
of the various factors of beta.
Essentially, for each factor
of beta in the denominator,
log Z will have a
minus log of beta.
I take a derivative, I will
get a factor of 1 over beta.
So from here, I will get 3/2
1 over beta, which is 3/2 kT.
So this is the center of mass.
From here, I have two
factors of beta to the 1/2.
So they combine to give
me one factor of kT.
This is for vibrations.
And similarly, I have
two factors of beta
to the 1/2, which correspond
to 1 kT for rotations.
So then I say that the heat
capacity at constant volume
is simply-- per particle
is related to d e1 by dT.
And I see that that amounts
to kb times 3/2 plus 1 plus 1,
or I should get 7/2 kb.
Per particle, which says that
if you go and calculate the heat
capacity of the
gas in this room,
divide by the
number of molecules
that we have-- doesn't
matter whether they
are oxygens or nitrogen.
They would basically give
the same contribution
because you can see
that the masses and all
the other properties
of the molecule
do not appear in
the heat capacity.
That as a function
of temperature,
I should get a value of 7/2.
So basically, C in units of kb.
So I divide by kb.
And my predictions is
that I should see 7/2.
So you go and do a measurement
and what do you get?
What you get is actually 5/2.
So something is not quite right.
We are not getting the
7/2 that we predicted.
Except that I really
mentioned that you
are getting this measurement
when you do measurements
at room temperature,
you get this value.
So when we measure
the heat capacity
of the gas in this
room, we will get 5/2.
But if we heat it
up, by the time
we get to temperatures of a
few thousand degrees Kelvin.
So if you heat the room
by a factor of 5 to 10,
you will actually
get the value of 7/2.
And if you cool
it, by the time you
get to the order of
10 degrees or fewer,
then you will find that
the heat capacity actually
goes even further.
It goes all the way to 3/2.
And the 3/2 is
the thing that you
would have predicted
for a gas that
had monatomic particles,
no internal structure.
Because then the only thing
that you would have gotten
is the center of
mass contribution.
So it seems like by going
to low temperatures,
you somehow freeze
the degrees of freedom
that correspond to vibrations
and rotations of the gas.
And by going to really
high temperatures,
you are able to liberate all
of these degrees of freedom
and store energy in them.
Heat capacity is the
measure of the ability
to store heat and energy
into these molecules.
So what is happening?
Well, by 1905,
Planck Had already
proposed that there is some
underlying quantization
for heat that you have
in the black body case.
And in 1905, Einstein
said, well, maybe we
should think about the
vibrational degrees
of the molecule also as
being similarly quantized.
So quantize vibrations.
It's totally a
phenomenological statement.
We have to justify it later.
But the statement is that for
the case where classically we
had a harmonic oscillator.
And let's say in
this case we would
have said that
its energy depends
on its momentum and its
position or displacement--
I guess I called it u--
through a formula such as this.
Certainly, you can pick
lots of values of u and p
that are compatible with
any value of the energy
that you choose.
But to get the
black body spectrum
to work, Planck had proposed
that really what you should do
is rather than thinking of
this harmonic oscillator
as being able to take all
possible values, that somehow
the values of energy that
it can take are quantized.
And furthermore, he
had proposed that they
are proportional to
the frequency involved.
And how did he guess that?
Ultimately, it was
related to what
I said about black
body radiation.
That as you heat
up the body, you
will find that there's
a light that comes out
and the frequency of
that light is somehow
related to temperature
and nothing else.
And based on that,
he had proposed
that frequencies should come
up in certain packages that
are proportional
to-- the energies
of the particular frequencies
should come in packages that
are proportional
to that frequency.
So there is an integer
here n that tells you
about the number
of these packets.
And not that it really matters
for what we are doing now,
but just to be consistent
with what we currently know
with quantum mechanics,
let me add the 0 point
energy of the harmonic
oscillator here.
So then, to calculate
the contribution
of a system in which energy
is in quantized packages,
you would say, OK,
I will calculate
a Z1 for these
vibrational levels,
assuming this
quantization of energy.
And so that says that
the possible states
of my harmonic
oscillator have energies
that are in these units
h bar omega n plus 1/2.
And if I still continue to
believe statistical mechanics,
I would say that
at a temperature t,
the probability that I
will be in a state that
is characterized by
integer n is e to the minus
beta times the energy that
corresponds to that integer n.
And then I can go and sum
over all possible energies
and that would be
the normalization
of the probability that
I'm in one of these states.
So this is e to the minus
beta h bar omega over 2
from the ground
state contribution.
The rest of it is simply
a geometric series.
Geometric series, we can sum
very easily to get 1 minus e
to the minus beta h bar omega.
And the interesting thing--
or a few interesting things
about this expression
is that if I
evaluate this in the
limit of low temperatures.
Well, actually, let's go
first to the high temperature
where beta goes to 0.
So t goes to become
large, beta goes to 0.
Numerator goes to 1, denominator
I can expand the exponential.
And to lowest order, I will
get 1 over beta h bar omega.
Now, compare this result
with the classical result
that we have over here
for the vibration.
Contribution of a harmonic
oscillator to the partition
function.
You can see that
the mu's cancel out.
I will get 1 over beta.
I will get h divided by 2 pi.
So if I call h divided
by 2 pi to be h bar,
then I will get
exactly this limit.
So somehow this constant
that we had introduced
that had dimensions
of action made
to make our calculations
of partition function
to be dimensionless
will be related
to this h bar that
quantizes the energy
levels through the
usual formula of h being
h bar-- h bar being h over 2 pi.
So basically, this
quantization of energy
clearly does not affect
the high temperature limit.
This oscillator at
high temperature
behaves exactly like what we
had calculated classically.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it h
equals h bar over 2 pi?
Or is it the other way, based
on your definitions above?
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Good.
All right?
So this is, I guess, the
corresponding formula.
Now, when you go to low
temperature, what do you get?
You essentially get the first
few terms in the series.
Because at the
lowest temperature
you get the term that
corresponds to n equals to 0,
and then you will
get corrections
from subsequent terms.
Now, what this does is that
it affects the heat capacity
profoundly.
So let's see how that happens.
So the contribution of 1
degrees of freedom to the energy
in this quantized fashion
d log Z by d beta.
So if I just take the
log of this expression,
log of this expression will get
this factor of minus beta h bar
omega over 2 from the numerator.
The derivative of that will
give you this ground state
energy, which is always there.
And then you'll have
to take the derivative
of the log of what
is coming out here.
Taking a derivative
with respect to beta,
we'll always pick out a
factor of h bar omega.
Indeed, it will pick out
a factor of h bar omega
e to the minus beta h bar omega.
And then in the denominator,
because I took the log,
I will get this expression back.
So again, in this
expression, if I
take the limit where beta
goes to 0, what do I get?
I will get this h
bar omega over 2.
It's always there.
Expanding these results here,
I will have a beta h bar omega.
It will cancel this and it
will give me a 1 over beta.
I will get this kT
that I had before.
Indeed, if I am correct
to the right order,
I will just simply
get 1 over beta.
Whereas, if I go to
large beta, what I get
is this h bar omega
over 2 plus a correction
from here, which is h bar omega
e to the minus beta h bar.
And that will be reflected
in the heat capacity, which
is dE by dT.
This h bar omega over 2 does
not continue to heat capacity,
not surprisingly.
From here, I have to take
derivatives with temperatures.
They appear in the combination
h bar omega over kT.
So what happens is
I will get something
that is of the order
of h bar omega.
And then from here, I
will get another h bar
omega divided by kb T squared.
I will write it in this fashion
and put the kb out here.
And then the rest
of these objects
will give me a
contribution that is minus
h bar omega over kT
divided by 1 minus e
to the minus h bar
omega over kT squared.
The important thing
is the following--
If I plot the heat
capacity that I
get from one of
these oscillators--
and the natural
units of all heat
capacities are kb, essentially.
Energy divided by temperature,
as kb has that units.
At high temperatures,
what I can see
is that the energy is
proportional to kT.
So heat capacity of the
vibrational degree of freedom
will be in these
units going to 1.
At low temperatures, however, it
becomes this exponentially hard
problem to create excitations.
Because of that, you
will get a contribution
that as T goes to 0 will
exponentially go to 0.
So the shape of the heat
capacity that you would get
will be something like this.
The natural way to
draw this figure
is actually what I
made the vertical axis
to be dimensionless.
So it goes between 0 and 1.
I can make the
horizontal axis to be
dimensionless by introducing
a theta of vibrations,
so that all of the exponential
terms are of the form e
to the minus T over this
theta of vibrations, which
means that this
theta of vibration
is h bar omega over kb.
That is, you tell me what the
frequency of your oscillator
is.
I can calculate the
corresponding temperature,
theta.
And then the heat capacity
of a harmonic oscillator
is this universal
function there, presumably
at some value that
is of the order of 1.
It switches from
being of the order
of 1 to going
exponentially to 0.
So basically, the dependence
down here to leading order
is e to the minus T
over theta vibration.
OK.
So you say, OK,
Planck has given us
some estimate of what
this h bar is based
on looking at the spectrum
of black body radiation.
We can, more or, less
estimate the typical energies
of interactions of molecules.
And from that, we
can estimate what
this frequency of vibration is.
So we should be able to
get an order of magnitude
estimate of what
this theta y is.
And what you find is that
theta y is of the order of 10
to the 3 degrees Kelvin.
It depends, of course, on
what gas you are looking at,
et cetera.
But as an order of magnitude,
it is something like that.
So we can now transport this
curve that we have over here
and more or less get this
first part of the curve
that we have over here.
So essentially, in this
picture what we have
is that there is no vibrations.
The vibrations have
been frozen out.
And here you have vibrations.
Of course, in all
of the cases, you
have the kinetic energy
of the center of mass.
And presumably since we are
getting the right answer
at very high temperatures now,
we also have the rotations.
And it makes sense
that essentially
what happened as we go
to very low temperatures
is that the rotations
are also frozen out.
Now, that's part of
the story-- actually,
you would think that among all
of the examples that I gave
you, this last one should be
the simplest thing because it's
really a two-body problem.
Whereas, solids you
have many things.
Radiation, you
have to think about
the electromagnetic
waves, et cetera.
That somehow,
historically, this would
be the one that
is resolved first.
And indeed, as I said
in 1905, Einstein
figured out
something about this.
But this part dealing with the
rotational degrees of freedom
and quantizing
them appropriately
had to really wait until you
had developed quantum mechanics
beyond the statement
that harmonic oscillators
are quantized in energy.
You had to know something more.
So since in retrospect we
do know something more,
let's finish and
give that answer
before going on
to something else.
OK?
So the next part of the
story of the diatomic gas
is quantizing rotations.
So currently what I have is that
there is an energy classically
for rotations that is
simply the kinetic energy
of rotational
degrees of freedom.
So there is an
angular momentum L,
and then there's
L squared over 2I.
It looks pretty much
like P squared over 2M,
except that the
degrees of freedom
for translation and
motion are positions.
They can be all over the place.
Whereas, the degrees
of freedom that you
have to think in
terms of rotations
are angles that go
between 0, 2 pi,
or on the surface of
a sphere, et cetera.
So once we figure out how
to do quantum mechanics,
we find that the
allowed values of this
are of the form h bar squared
over 2I l, l plus 1, where
l now is the number that gives
you the discrete values that
are possible for the square
of the angular momentum.
So you say OK, let's calculate
a Z for the rotational degrees
of freedom assuming this
kind of quantization.
So what I have to do, like I
did for the harmonic oscillator,
is I sum over all possible
values of l that are allowed.
The energy e to the minus
beta h bar squared over 2I
l, l plus 1.
Except that there
is one other thing,
which is that these
different values of l
have degeneracy
that is 2l plus 1.
And so you have to multiply by
the corresponding degeneracy.
So what am I doing over here?
I have to do a sum over
different values of l,
contributions that are
really the probability that I
am in these different values of
the index l-- 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6.
And I have to add all
of these contributions.
Now, the first
thing that I will do
is I ask whether the limit
of high temperatures that I
had calculated before is
correctly reproduced or not.
So I have to go to the limit
where temperature is high
or beta goes to 0.
If beta goes to 0,
you can see that going
from one l to another
l, it is multiply
this exponent by a small number.
So what does that mean?
It means that the values from
one point to another point
of what am I summing over is
not really that different.
And I can think of a
continuous curve that
goes through all
of these points.
So if I do that, then
I can essentially
replace the sum
with an integral.
In fact, you can systematically
calculate corrections
to replacing the sum with
an integral mathematically
and you have a problem set
that shows you how to do that.
But now what I can do is I
can call this combination l, l
plus 1 x.
And then dx will
simply be 2l plus 1 dl.
So essentially, the
degeneracy works out precisely
so that when I go to the
continuum limit, whatever
quantization I had for
these angular momenta
corresponds to the
weight or measure
that I would have in stepping
around the l-directions.
And then, this is something
that I can easily do.
It's just an integral dx
e to the minus alpha x.
The answer is going to be 1 over
alpha, or the answer to this
is simply 2I beta h bar squared.
So this is the classical
limit of the expression
that we had over here.
Let's go and see what we had
when we did things classically.
So when we did
things classically,
I had two factors of
h and 2 pi and 4 pi.
So I can write the whole
thing as h bar squared and 2.
I have I, and then I have beta.
And you can see that
this is exactly what we
have over there.
So once more, properly
accounting for phase space,
measure, productive p
q's being dimension--
made dimensionless
by this quantity h
is equivalent to the
high temperature limit
that you would get
in quantum mechanics
where things are discretized.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you're
talking about the quantum
interpretations, then h
bar is the precise value
of Planck's constant, which
can be an experimental measure.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: But when
you're talking
about the classical derivations,
h is just some factor
that we mention of
curve dimension.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
comparing the limits
of large temperatures,
how can you
be sure to establish the
h bar in two places means
the same thing?
PROFESSOR: So far,
I haven't told
you anything to justify that.
So when we were doing
things classically,
we said that just to make
things dimensionless,
let's introduce this
quantity that we call h.
Now, I have shown you
two examples where
if you do things quantum
mechanically properly
and take the limit of
going to high temperatures,
you will see that the
h that you would get--
because the quantum
mechanical partition functions
are dimensionless
quantities, right?
So these are
dimensionless quantities.
They have to be made
dimensionless by something.
They're made dimensionless
by Boltzmann's constant.
By a Planck's constant, h bar.
And we can see
that as long as we
are consistent with this
measure of phase space,
the same constant shows up both
for the case of the vibrations,
for the case of the rotations.
And very soon, we will
see that it will also
arise in the case of
the center of mass.
And so there is certainly
something in the transcriptions
that we ultimately will make
between quantum mechanics
and classical mechanics
that must account for this.
And somehow in the limit where
quantum mechanics is dealing
with large energies,
it is indistinguishable
from classical mechanics.
And quantum partition
functions are--
all of the countings that we do
in quantum mechanics are kind
of unambiguous because we are
dealing with discrete levels.
So if you remember the
original part of the difficulty
was that we could define
things like entropy only
properly when we
had discrete levels.
If we had a continuum
probability distribution
and if we made a
change of variable,
then the entropy was changed.
But in quantum mechanics,
we don't have that problem.
We have discretized values
for the different states.
Probabilities will be-- once
we deal with them appropriately
be discretized.
And all of the things
here are dimensionless.
And somehow they reproduce the
correct classical dynamics.
Quantum mechanics goes
to classical mechanics
in the appropriate
high-energy limit.
And what we find is that what
happens is that this shows up.
If you like, another
way of achieving--
why is there this
correspondence?
In classical
statistical mechanics,
I emphasize that I should really
write h in units of p and q.
And it was only when I
calculated partition functions
in coordinates p and q that were
canonically conjugate that I
was getting results
that were meaningful.
One way of constructing
quantum mechanics
is that you take the
Hamiltonian and you change these
into operators.
And you have to impose these
kinds of commutation relations.
So you can see that somehow
the same prescription in terms
of phase space appears both
in statistical mechanics,
in calculating measures
of partition function,
in quantum mechanics.
And not surprisingly, you have
introduced in quantum mechanics
some unit for phase space p, q.
It shows up in
classical mechanics
as the quantity [INAUDIBLE].
But there is, indeed,
a little bit more work
than I have shown you
here that one can do.
Once we have developed
the appropriate formalism
for quantum statistical
mechanics, which
is this [INAUDIBLE] performed
and appropriate quantities
defined for partition
functions, et cetera,
in quantum statistical
mechanics that we
will do in a couple of lectures.
Then if you take the
limit h bar goes to 0,
you should get the classical
integration over phase space
with this factor
of h showing up.
But right now, we
are just giving you
some heuristic response.
If I go, however, in
the other limit, where
beta is much larger
than 1, what do I get?
Basically, then
all of the weight
is going to be in the
lowest energy level, 0, 1.
And then the rest of them
will be exponentially small.
I cannot replace the
sum with an integral,
so basically I will get a
contribution that starts with 1
for l equals to 0.
And then I will get
3e to the minus beta h
bar squared divided by 2I.
l being 1, this will
give me 1 times 2.
So I will have a 2 here.
And then, higher-order terms.
So once you have the
partition function,
you go through
the same procedure
as we described before.
You calculate the energy,
which is d log Z by d beta.
What do you get?
Again, in the high
temperature limit
you will get the same
answer as before.
So you will get beta goes to 0.
You will get kT.
If you go to the low
temperature limit-- well,
let's be more precise.
What do I mean by
low temperatures?
Beta larger than what?
Clearly, the unit that
is appearing everywhere
is this beta h bar squared
over 2I, which has units of 1
over temperature from beta.
So I can introduce a
theta for rotations
to make this demonstrate
that this is dimensionless.
So the theta that
goes with rotations
is h bar squared over 2I kb.
And so what I mean by going
to the low temperatures
is that I go for
temperatures that
are much less than the
theta of these rotations.
And then what happens is
that essentially this state
will occur with exponentially
small probability
and will contribute to
the energy and amount that
is of the order of h
bar squared 2I times 2.
That's the energy of
the l equals to 1 state.
There are three of them, and
they occur with probability e
to the minus theta
rotation divided
by T times a factor of 2.
All of those factors is
not particularly important.
Really, the only thing
that is important
is that if I look now at the
rotational heat capacity, which
again should properly
have units of kb,
as a function of temperature.
Well, temperatures
I have to make
dimensionless by dividing by
this rotational heat capacity.
I say that at
high, temperature I
get the classical result back.
So basically, I will get
to 1 at high temperatures.
At low temperatures, again
I have this situation
that there is a gap in
the allowed energies.
So there is the lowest
energy, which is 0.
The next one, the first type of
rotational mode that is allowed
has a finite energy
that is larger than that
by an amount that is of the
order of h bar squared over I.
And if I am at these
temperatures that
are less than this
theta of rotation,
I simply don't
have enough energy
from thermal fluctuations
to get to that level.
So the occupation of that level
will be exponentially small.
And so I will have a curve that
will, in fact, look something
like this.
So again, you basically
go over at a temperature
of the order of 1
from heat capacity
that is order of 1 to heat
capacity that is exponentially
small when you get to
temperatures that are lower
than this rotational
temperature.
AUDIENCE: Is that
over-shooting, or is that--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you have a
problem set where you
calculate the next correction.
So there is the summation
replacing the sum
with an integral.
This gives you this
to the first order,
and then there's a correction.
And you will show that
the correction is such
that there is actually
the approach to one
for the case of the rotational
heat capacity is from above.
Whereas, for the
vibrational heat capacity,
it is from below.
So there is, indeed,
a small bump.
OK?
So you can ask, well, I
know the typical size of one
of these oxygen molecules.
I know the mass.
I can figure out what the
moment of inertia I is.
I put it over here and I figure
out what the theta of rotation
is.
And you find that, again, as a
matter of order of magnitudes,
theta of rotations is of
the order of 10 degrees
K. So this kind of accounts for
why when you go to sufficiently
low temperatures for the
heat capacity of the gas
in this room, we
see that essentially
the rotational degrees of
freedom are also frozen out.
OK.
So now let's go to the
second item that we have,
which is the heat
capacity of the solid.
So what do I mean?
So this is item 2,
heat capacity of solid.
And you measure heat
capacities for some solid
as a function of temperature.
And what you find is
that the heat capacity
has a behavior such as this.
So it seems to
vanish as you to go
to lower and lower temperatures.
So what's going on here?
Again, Einstein looked at
this and said, well, it's
another case of the story of
vibrations and some things
that we have looked at here.
And in fact, I really don't
have to do any calculation.
I'll do the following.
Let's imagine that this is
what we have for the solid.
It's some regular arrangement
of atoms or molecules.
And presumably, this
is the situation
that I have at 0 temperature.
Everybody is
sitting nicely where
they should be to
minimize the energy.
If I go to finite temperature,
then these atoms and molecules
start to vibrate.
And he said, well,
basically, I can
estimate the frequencies
of vibrations.
And what I will do is I
will say that each atom is
in a cage by its neighbors.
That is, this particular atom
here, if it wants to move,
it find that its distance to
the neighbors has been changed.
And if I imagine
that there are kind
of springs that are
connecting this atom only
to its neighbors,
moving around there
will be some kind of
a restoring force.
So it's like it is
sitting in some kind
of a harmonic potential.
And if it tries to
move, it will experience
this restoring force.
And so it will have some
kind of a frequency.
So each atom vibrates
at some frequency.
Let's call it omega E.
Now, in principle,
in this picture
if this cage is not
exactly symmetric,
you may imagine that
oscillations in the three
different directions could
give you different frequencies.
But let's ignore that and let's
imagine that the frequencies is
the same in all of these.
So what have we done?
We have reduced the problem
of the excitation energy
that you can put in the
atoms of the solid to be
the same now as 3N harmonic
oscillators of frequency omega.
Why 3N?
Because each atom
essentially sees restoring
force in three directions.
And forgetting about
boundary effects,
it's basically
three per particle.
So you would have said that
the heat capacity that I would
calculate per particle
in units of kb
should essentially be exactly
what we have over here,
except that I multiply by 3
because each particular has
3 possible degrees of freedom.
So all I need to do is
to take that green curve
and multiply it
by a factor of 3.
And indeed, the limiting value
that you get over here is 3.
Except that if I just
take that green curve
and superpose it on
this, what I will get
is something like this.
So this is 3 times
harmonic oscillator.
What do I mean by that, is
I try to sort of do my best
to match the
temperature at which you
go from one to the other.
But then what I find is that
as we had established before,
the green curve goes
to 0 exponentially.
So there is going to be
some theta associated
with this frequency.
Let's call it theta
Einstein divided by T.
And so the prediction
of this model
is that the heat capacities
should vanish very rapidly
as this form of exponential.
Whereas, what is actually
observed in the experiment
is that it is going
to 0 proportional
to T cubed, which is a
much slower type of decay.
OK?
AUDIENCE: That's
negative [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: As T goes to 0,
the heat capacity goes to 0.
T to the third power.
So it's the limit-- did I
make a mistake somewhere else?
All right.
So what's happening here?
OK, so what's happening
is the following.
In some average
sense, it is correct
that if you try to oscillate
some atom in the crystal,
it's going to have some
characteristic restoring force.
The characteristic
restoring force
will give you some
corresponding typical scale
for the frequencies
of the vibrations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is this the
historical progression?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, it seems
interesting that they
would know that-- like this
cage hypothesis is very good,
considering where a
quantum [INAUDIBLE] exists.
I don't understand how
that's the logic based--
if what we know is the
top board over there,
the logical progression is that
you would have-- I don't know.
PROFESSOR: No.
At that time, the proposal
was that essentially
if you have oscillator
of frequency omega,
its energy is quantized
in multiples of omega.
So that's really the only
aspect of quantum mechanics.
So I actually jumped the
historical development
where I gave you the
rotational degrees of freedom.
So as I said, historically this
was resolved last in this part
because they didn't know
what to do with rotations.
But now I'm saying that
you know about rotations,
you know that the heat
capacity goes to 0.
You say, well,
solid is composed.
The way that you put
heat into the system,
enhance its heat capacity, is
because there is kinetic energy
that you put in the
atoms of the solid.
And as you try to
put kinetic energy,
there is this cage model
and there's restoring force.
The thing that is
wrong about this model
is that, basically, if you ask
how easy it is to give energy
to the system, if rather
than having one frequency
you have multiple frequencies,
then at low temperatures
you would put energy
in the lower frequency.
Because the typical scale we
saw for connecting temperature
and frequency, they are kind
of proportional to each other.
So if you want to go
to low temperature,
you are bound to excite things
that have lower frequency.
So the thing is that
it is true that there
is a typical frequency.
But the typical frequency
becomes less and less important
as you go to low temperature.
The issue is, what are
the lowest frequencies
of excitation?
And basically, the
correct picture
of excitations of the solid
is that you bang on something
and you generate
these sound waves.
So what you have is that
oscillations or vibrations
of solid are characterized
by wavelength and wave number
k, 2 pi over lambda.
So if I really take a
better model of the solid
in which I have springs that
connect all of these things
together and ask, what are
the normal modes of vibration?
I find that the normal
modes can be characterized
by some wave number k.
As I said, it's the
inverse of the wavelength.
And frequency depends
on wave number.
In a manner that when you go
to 0k, frequency goes to 0.
And why is that?
Essentially, what I'm
saying is that if you
look at particles
that are along a line
and may be connected by springs.
So a kind of one-dimensional
version of a solid.
Then, the normal modes
are characterized
by distortions that have
some particular wavelength.
And in the limit
where the wavelength
goes to 0, essentially--
Sorry, in the limit
where the wavelength goes
to infinity or k
goes to 0, it looks
like I am taking
all of the particles
and translating them together.
And if I take the entire
solid here and translate it,
there is no restoring force.
So omega has to go to
0 as your k goes to 0,
or wavelength goes to infinity.
And there is a symmetry
between k and minus k,
in fact, that forces
the restoring force
to be proportional to k squared.
And when you take the
square root of that,
you get the frequency.
You always get a linear
behavior as k goes to 0.
So essentially,
that's the observation
that whatever you
do with your solid,
no matter how complicated,
you have sound modes.
And sound modes are
things that happen
in the limit where you
have long wavelengths
and there is a relationship
between omega and k
through some kind of
velocity of sound.
Now, to be precise
there are really
three types of sound waves.
If I choose the
direction k along which
I want to create an
oscillation, the distortions
can be either along that
direction or perpendicular
to that.
They can either be
longitudinal or transfers.
So there could be one
or two other branches.
So there could, in principle,
be different straight lines
as k goes to 0.
And the other
thing is that there
is a shortest wavelength
that you can think about.
So if these particles
are a distance a apart,
there is no sense in
going to wave numbers that
are larger than pi over a.
So you have some
limit to these curves.
And indeed, when you
approach the boundary,
this linear dependence
can shift and change
in all kinds of possible ways.
And calculating the
frequency inside one
of these units that is
called a Brillouin zone
is a nice thing
to do for the case
of using methods of solid state.
And you've probably seen that.
And there is a whole
spectrum of frequencies
as a function of
wave number that
correctly characterize a solid.
So it may be that somewhere
in the middle of this spectrum
is a typical frequency
omega E. But the point is
that as you go to lower
and lower temperatures,
because of these factors of e
to the minus beta h bar omega,
you can see that as you go to
lower and lower temperature,
the only things that get
excited are omegas that are also
going to 0
proportionately to kT.
So I can draw a line here that
corresponds to frequencies that
are of the order
of kT over h bar.
All of the harmonic
oscillators that
have these larger frequencies
that occur at short wavelengths
are unimportant.
They're kind of frozen,
just like the vibrations
of the oxygen molecules
in this room are frozen.
You cannot put energy in them.
They don't contribute
to heat capacity.
But all of these
long wavelength modes
down here have
frequencies that go to 0.
Their excitation
possibility is large.
And it, indeed,
these long wavelength
modes that are easy to excite
and continue to heat capacity.
I'll do maybe the precise
calculation next time,
but even within this
picture we can figure out
why the answer should be
proportional to T cubed.
So what I need to do,
rather than counting
all harmonic oscillators--
the factor of 3n--
I have to count how many
oscillators have frequencies
that are less than
this kT over h bar.
So I claim that number of modes
with frequency less than kT
over h bar goes like
kT over h bar cubed V.
Essentially, what
I have to do is
to do a summation over all k
that is less than some k max.
This k max is set
by this condition
that Vk max is of the
order of kT over h bar.
So this k max is of the
order of kT over h bar V.
So actually, to be more
precise I have to put a V here.
So I have to count
all of the modes.
Now, this separation
between these modes--
if you have a box of
size l is 2 pi over l.
So maybe we will
discuss that later on.
But the summations
over k you will always
replace with
integrations over k times
the density of state, which
is V divided by 2 pi cubed.
So this has to go
between 0 and k max.
And so this is
proportional to V k max
cubed, which is what
I wrote over there.
So as I go to lower
and lower temperature,
there are fewer and
fewer oscillators.
The number of those
oscillators grows like T cubed.
Each one of those
oscillators is fully excited
as energy kT contributes
1 unit to heat capacity.
Since the number of oscillators
goes to 0 as T cubed,
the heat capacity that
they contribute also
goes to 0 as T cubed.
So you don't really need
to know-- this is actually
an interesting thing to ponder.
So rather than doing
the calculations,
maybe just think about this.
That somehow the solid could
be arbitrarily complicated.
So it could be
composed of molecules
that have some particular shape.
They are forming
some strange lattice
of some form, et cetera.
And given the complicated
nature of the molecules,
the spectrum that you have
for potential frequencies
that a solid can
take, because of all
of the different
vibrations, et cetera,
could be arbitrary complicated.
You can have kinds of
oscillations such as the ones
that I have indicated.
However, if you go
to low temperature,
you are only interested
in vibrations
that are very low in frequency.
Vibrations that are
very low in frequencies
must correspond
to the formations
that are very long wavelength.
And when you are
looking at things
that are long wavelength,
this is, again,
another thing that has
statistical in character.
That is, rather you
are here looking
at things that span thousands
of atoms or molecules.
However, as you go to lower
and lower temperature,
more and more atoms
and molecules.
And so again, some kind of
averaging is taking place.
All of the details,
et cetera, wash out.
You really see some
global characteristic.
The global characteristic
that you see
is set by this symmetry.
Just the fact that when I
go to exactly k equals to 0,
I am translating.
I have 0 frequency.
So when I'm doing something
that is long wavelength,
the frequency should
somehow be proportional
to that wavelength.
So that's just a statement
of continuity if you like.
Once I have made that
statement, then it's
just a calculation of how
many modes are possible.
The number of modes will
be proportional to T cubed.
And I will get this T
cubed law irrespective
of how complicated the solid is.
All of the solids will have
the same T cubed behavior.
The place where they come
from the classical behavior
to this quantum
behavior will depend
on the details of
the solid, et cetera.
But the low temperature
law, this T cubed law,
is something that is universal.
OK, so next time around,
we will do this calculation
in more detail, and then
see also its connection
to the blackbody radius.